hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled rapid discovery of
therapeutic antibodies for Tsarskoe d2
and other viral pandemics this webinar
is a part of the ongoing coronavirus
virtual webinar series i am michelle
ashton of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
laberd's and sponsored by Berkley lights
for more information about our sponsor
please visit www.hp.com/recycle
I would like to remind everyone that
this event is interactive we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you'd like
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send well answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen as a reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits I now present today's speaker
dr. Anupam single the product manager of
antibody therapeutics at Berkley lights
for a complete biography on dr. single
please visit by biography tab at the top
of your screen
dr. single you may now begin your
presentation
you
humans are susceptible to a myriad of
different pathogenic viruses including
HIV influenza Zika virus Ebola and the
severe acute respiratory syndrome
coronavirus - known as SARS Kobe - these
viruses can result in a wide range of
diseases with symptoms ranging from
common flu-like symptoms to death
development of therapeutics against each
virus has its unique set of challenges
including rapid transmission high
mutation rate and delayed onset of
symptoms these are long latency times
the current coded 19 pandemic is a
dramatic example of the challenge of
curtailing the rapidly transmitting
Tsarskoe v2 virus in a matter of months
toven 19 turned from a regional disease
in Hubei Province China to a global
pandemic that is infected greater than
500,000 people and killing over 20,000
as of March 26 2020 these numbers are
continuing to expand daily in response
to infection the human immune system
produces antibodies that bind viruses
and target them for clearance
unfortunately some exposed individuals
do not produce viral neutralizing
antibodies which may result in serious
life-threatening diseases in these
instances administration of neutralizing
antibodies known as passive
immunotherapy may protect individuals
from infection or enable them to recover
post infection as a result the rapid
discovery of antibodies against viruses
is a promising strategy for combating
viruses for the Tsarskoe v2 virus
antibody is targeting the spike protein
may prevent binding of the virus to the
human ace to receptor thus preventing
infection
up Toby cell antibody discovery on the
beacon system bypasses in efficient
algorithm effusion by directly screening
B cells from immunized animals or human
patients B cells are harvested and
purified from diverse B cell
compartments including peripheral blood
spleen bone marrow and lymph nodes these
cells are functionally screened on the
beacon system and antigen specific
sequences are recovered in less than one
week the beacon system fully automates
cell sample handling screening t DNA
synthesis and sequence recovery a
96-well plate containing a purified B
cell sample is inserted into the beacon
the beacon system then automatically
loads the cell sample into opto select
chips
tens of thousands of cells can be
screened in up to select chips
containing men appends each less than
one nanometer in volume greater than ten
thousand times smaller than a well in
the 96-well plate the small volumes
enables secreted antibody concentrations
to reach detectable levels in a matter
of minutes
these cells are cloned into men appends
using berkeley license up to-- select
technology in which cells are
manipulated by light
you
this light based manipulation can be
performed in parallel across hundreds to
thousands of cells several tens of
thousands of b-cells can be cloned
across multiple chips in less than two
hours
nann open chambers enable rapid precise
and highly sensitive assets in minutes
secreted antibodies from b-cells can be
assayed to determine antigen specificity
in this assay the target antigen is
conjugated to beads and mixed with a
secondary antibody prior to importing
into the chip to create those antibodies
from b-cells diffuse out of pens and
bind the antigen coated beads the
secondary antibody is then sequestered
on the beads to provide a rapid
fluorescent readout in a matter of
minutes
this essay is performed on tens of
thousands of cells simultaneously in
this field of view hundreds of cells are
screened to identify less than a dozen
hit
The Beacon enables down selection of
lead candidates through multiple assays
for antigen specificity and function
that can be performed either in serial
or in parallel better characterization
upfront reduces the expense of having to
sequence or clone irrelevant
non-functional hits in a pandemic
situation there is often little control
over the available patient samples opto
b-cell discovery enables screening of
b-cells from acute or convalescent
patients plasma b-cells can be enriched
from fresh PBMCs obtained from acutely
infected patients alternatively memory
b-cells can be enriched from thawed
frozen PBMC samples and activated off
chip in tissue culture prior to
screening
we demonstrated the screening for frozen
PBMC samples that were obtained from
healthy human donors the samples were
thawed and memory b-cells were purified
by fax or max the memory B cells were
activated in tissue culture for four
days using a proprietary B cell
activation media the activated memory
b-cells were then screened on chip to
confirm antibody IgG secretion
we can identify antiviral antibodies
from purified human b-cells
full-length viral proteins or their
subunits can be conjugated to beads and
antigen specific antibodies are detected
using a fluorescently labeled anti human
secondary antibody in the images here we
detected antibodies that were specific
and cross-reactive against the
full-length spike protein and receptor
binding domain for SARS Kobe - virus
this work was performed in collaboration
with Rob Carnahan and James crow in
their lab at the Vanderbilt University
Medical Center we have demonstrated a
proof-of-concept viral neutralization
assay using a vesicular stomatitis
pseudo virus engineered to express the
ebola Lyco protein we created a set of
hex cell lines secreting either
neutralizing or non neutralizing
antibodies and mixed these together we
then loaded single heck cells with veera
cells into individual nano pens we used
our standard V based assay to confirm
that the heck cells were secreting
antibodies and simultaneously we
identified pens in which antibodies
blocked viral infection as confirmed by
the absence of expression of a
fluorescent GFP marker in the vero cells
this assay demonstrates that we can
successfully identify cells that are
secreting viral neutralizing antibodies
after identification of hit antigen
specific antibody sequences are
recovered via unloading of cells or
unloading of beads on which on ship C
DNA synthesis has been performed after
recovery off ship amplification of heavy
and light chain genes is performed in
just two days up Toby cell antibody
discovery enables single cell cloning
screening on ship genomics and
sequencing of antigen specific antibody
sequences
we have active collaborations throughout
the world to develop new therapeutic
antibodies and vaccines for Cove is 19
our collaborators have already leveraged
the speed of our platform to discover
greater than 500 antibodies to SARS Kobe
- in a single day please reach out to us
if you are interested to learn more and
join us in our Global Emerging pathogen
and antibody discovery consortium in the
fight against kovat 19 thank you
you
you
Thank You dr. Singhal for your
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen let's get started ok your
first question here is what C can be
cell discovery on the beacon system
green human patient samples
yes so the opto b-cell discovery
platform will work with both human and
b-cell samples as well as Mouse b-cells
samples and it's compatible with fresh
plasma B cells as well as activated
memory b-cells
great thank you how many antibodies can
be discovered from a single b-cell
sample
we've demonstrated from immunized mice
that we can discover greater than 5,000
hits per sample and we leverage the
ability to keep plasma b-cells viable
and tissue culture for multiple days so
that we can perform multiple workflows
on a single sample and as mentioned in
the presentation we have collaborators
who are working on copan 19 who have
discovered greater than 500 antigen
specific or viral specific antibodies in
a single day
great thank you okay it looks like your
next question is are all isotopes of
immunoglobulins can be detected in
b-cells
yes there is a principle no restriction
on which isotypes are assayed and in in
these in this workflow and the selection
of secondary detection reagent will
determine which isotype is being acid
for
now can you describe what memory b-cells
from blood samples do they give you an
idea about the mucosal immunity
so we haven't done any specific studies
of mucosal immunity and but we do know
that B cells can be screened from from
multiple different B cell compartments
and organs
thank you we've got lots of great
questions coming in from the audience
and here's your next one what is the
efficiency of sequence recovery from B
cells screened during the workflow
we've recently launched this up to CPC
our capability which reliably recovers
greater than 85% of paired heavy and
light chain sequences from single
b-cells
right thank you okay your next one is
are you able to recover all cells from
the chip or do you notice that you lose
cells during the process
so we by performing up to cbcr we now do
on chip cDNA synthesis on beads and so
we are now recovering beads rather than
the cells and our recovery process now
is highly efficient so that we we obtain
sequences from greater than 80% of all
antigen specific antibodies of interest
now there's a second part to that
question and it says how does the export
of cells work technically
wait so as with the cell loading we use
this Optive select technology to bring
beads or cells out into the channel and
then activate the fluidics to export the
samples into 96-well plates
now under the antibodies change with the
mutations of kovat night gene we've
demonstrated that by performing multiple
assays with different antigen variants
you can identify antibodies that are
specific or cross-reactive against
multiple targets so in this case if you
were screening against different
variants of the spike protein in a
single experiment single workflow you'd
expect to find antibodies again that are
specific to particular variants and
cross-reactive against multiple areas
great thank you okay your next question
here says do you work with other surface
proteins of Tsarskoe b2 for the antibody
production
our own internal experiences have been
with passing against the spiked protein
as well as the RBD of that spiked
protein for SARS Kobe - in principle all
of the other surface proteins of the
virus can be assayed and select na
devised can be selected for them and I
believe that we have customers that are
targeting a wide very wide array of
different targets on the virus
now following that question can other
surface proteins of Sarco be to be good
target of antibody production
and we believe today the scientific
community has identified that viruses
enter human cells using the viral spy
protein which is why and this has
attracted the greatest attention as a
potential drug target
great thank you
well the antibody caused acute lung
disease
so there is still extensive preclinical
and clinical testing required for any
new drug therapeutic including
antibodies that are discovered on our
platform or any other platform
are all surface proteins due to the
induced antibodies
so we're able to screen any sample from
an immunized animal or human in which
there has been an immune response
great please deal and I just want to
remind the audience if you'd like to
submit a question you can do so now just
go ahead and type your question into the
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen as a reminder if
there's any questions we don't get to
today they will be followed up via email
after the presentation is over and we'll
give the audience just a few minutes to
submit some questions
if there are no further questions at
this moment I'd like to once again thank
dr. Singhal for his educational
presentation do you have any final
comments for our audience
yeah I encourage you to seek us out if
you're interested in our anti discovery
platform and especially if you are
interested in our current fight against
Ovid 19
q and thanks again for your time today
and your important research before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their questions
I'd also like to thank our sponsor
Berkley lights for sponsoring today's
webinar any questions we did not have
time for today and submitted during the
on demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through the end of this year 2020
laberd's will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event please also visit the Berkley
lights booths now in the exhibit hall to
receive more information until next time
goodbye
you